[Music]
what's the real reason we purchase items
such as campers boats off-roading
vehicles cabins and vacation homes
is it because we hope to create memories
with people through these objects
so she sort of answered her own question
here
i think that's half of it don't you ryan
sure
we i think maybe the most charitable
thing is oh i hope to create memories
with my vacation home
or even just experiences
i rarely ever hope to create memories i
don't find memories very useful but i
find the experiences to be wildly useful
and those the the memories are sort of
like a byproduct of that right yeah
now the experience of any of these
things an off-roading vehicle you've
gone off-roading almost killed yourself
several times
and you have an amazing experience with
that right yeah however some of these
things like a vacation home for example
can also be a wonderful experience or it
can be
look at me
look what i own aren't you impressed
ryan
yeah i mean when it comes to a vacation
home i like i know people who have
vacation homes that
use them on a regular basis it makes me
think about an ex-girlfriend of mine
they had a
family vacation home on the lake it was
literally a garage that they purchased
and then
themselves like they remodeled it to be
um three bedrooms one bathroom it was
probably 700 square feet i mean it was
so so tiny right but they went down
there in the summer time they go down
there every other week
um
you know something like that yeah it
makes sense they are creating memories
they're going to the lake they're having
a good time they're wakeboarding they're
boating they're swimming or whatever it
is
um
but if you're
buying a vacation home
to use it once or twice a year
like that's where it's like
you might just want to rent something
out go get a time share yeah and it's
funny because timeshares have such a bad
rap but it actually makes sense well
they have a bad rap for a good reason oh
yeah they're a huge waste of money and
they're over inflated and yes yeah there
are whole companies that are dedicated
to getting people out of their
timeshares i would rather have a time
share though
and you know on the lake that i could go
to once or twice a year yeah than have
the debt of a
of a vacation house mortgage right or or
the third option is how can i how can i
have this without the timeshare or the
mortgage and airbnb is a great option
airbnb is effectively a timeshare right
it's just more flexible and if you don't
want to return to that same location you
can go somewhere else it gives you that
that flexibility yeah what's the other
one vr bo or whatever yeah um
there are a bunch of options here that
you so you don't have to feel pigeon
holed into it because quite often these
luxury items
the boat the vacation house what else
did uh did she mention here the
off-roading vehicles the cabins the
campers the whatever else um
all of these things a lot of people get
immense value from yeah but some people
get dragged by their boat and not in a
fun way well you know they make these
aspirational yeah they make these
aspirational
purchases
like they they we're gonna create the
memories and we need this to create the
memories it's
and i think that's where we fool
ourselves you don't need a vacation
house to create meaningful vacation
memories oh yeah you don't need a
vacation home in order to vacation yeah
tweet that podcast sean now the the
other side of that is also like i want
to be the type of person who goes
boating
but i know like i get seasick it'd be
the dumbest thing but i want to be that
kind of person well why do i want to be
that person well it's something that
i've i've coined as memetic meaning
some people find meaning in boating and
exploration like that and all of a
sudden i feel as though because they
find meaning in that i'm supposed to as
well
so i'm the type of person who needs to
own a boat now or i aspire to be that
type of person i'll never be that kind
of person and it's okay understanding in
fact as soon as you understand it the
allure of the boat fades immediately
yeah
man you seem like a very nautical person
to me josh
[Laughter]
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free